hi
i'm happy to present new updates and
exciting announcements
for serverless workflows in google cloud
my name is philipp knapik and i'm a
product manager working on workflow
products
workflows is a very broad term let's
first look into some use cases and needs
around them
let's imagine an ecommerce application a
workflow that needs to orchestrate
a couple of steps for instance first
create an invoice then
generate a pdf and then send it to a
customer over
email you want a workflow product not
only to manage
and orchestrate execution of those steps
but also for instance recover from
errors that those steps may encounter
another use case that you may want to
manage with a workflow product
is processing of a batch of transactions
or events or customer records
and then for each of those you may want
to look into the contents
and make a decision on whether to take a
path with
additional steps like for instance
you're looking into business
transactions
checking if they're overdue and if so
sending a reminder
to affected users or customers
but workflows don't have to be focused
on business transactions only
they can also help in automation of it
landscape like for instance you want to
start a virtual machine
then wait for some time check whether
specific conditions are met like for
instance application is up and running
and if so take an action and if not take
another action
and obviously there is many other use
cases in it automation space
and others and workflow products are
expected to be very
flexible in automating work across
different types of endpoints and apis
now what do all those use cases have in
common
there is a set of foundational needs
that
a product needs to support in order to
enable implementation of a workflow in a
production environment
the first and probably most important
element
is reliable execution of steps again in
the business scenario in the production
deployment we can't afford to
fail an execution of a workflow just
because there was a temporary network
outage and a single step
was affected and a single step wasn't
properly
executed and as such a workflow product
needs to be able to recover from some of
those errors and
handle exceptions or retry steps as
needed to maximize the chance of
successful execution another
feature that a workflow product needs to
have is efficient
handover of the work and it's not only
handover of the work and orchestration
of steps
what a workflow product also needs to
provide for is
is transition and handover of the data
between those steps because individual
steps
can produce data that other steps may
rely on in their execution
decision execution is another aspect
that is important for
workflow products imagine that you are
building a workflow that is processing
your orders
or orders from your customers and you
want to execute a different path
if an order exceeds a specific threshold
let's say
beyond or above one thousand dollars you
want to assign
a sales engineer or sales specialist to
that customer
to assist them because the deal is so
big and in order for you to implement
such decisions as part of your workflow
directly
you want to have a feature that allows
you to manage execution in a different
way
provided that specific conditions are
met
workflows don't always integrate apis or
products of the same type
you may want to orchestrate work across
different products
using different api languages using
different
http methods different authentication
models or even hosted in different
places
and a workflow product needs to be able
to integrate them all
regardless of their diversity and
differences in implementation
last but not least of the features that
i would like to call out
is a holistic perspective on execution
and management of your workflows
first of all imagine that a third step
of a workflow fails
you need to be able to understand what
was the business transaction that this
step failed in
to be able to recover from it or you may
also need to see
how many workflow executions you had for
a specific customer
or in specific domain all those features
are very important for a workflow
product
and when looking into those we have
realized that
our customers would greatly benefit from
an introduction
of a serverless workflow orchestration
product as part of google cloud
and with that i'm very happy to announce
a new product in google cloud family
workflows what this product is expected
to
address is orchestration and integration
of different types of apis
first of all integration of serverless
compute
products let's say you want to create a
workflow consisting of different cloud
functions
and you want to effectively and
efficiently hand the work over in
between them this is a great use case
for
workflows or the same for cloud run but
we don't want to stop here
you can also create a workflow that for
instance reads
the data from firestore or pushes a
message to pub sub
or doing any other operation in other
google cloud apis
and this is also not where we wanted to
stop because we understand that our
customers are running in hybrid
environments
and often rely on for instance software
as a service apis
hosted externally to our cloud and
therefore workflows products also
support
direct calls to external apis as part of
the workflow definition
including all of the handling of errors
retries
and everything around it so this product
is expected to help our customers in
orchestration of work across
practically speaking any of the apis
within google cloud or external
and integration of those apis in a
holistic way to enable
implementation of workflows the product
is fully managed and fully automated we
want our customers to focus
on the business logic of the workflow
rather than focusing on the underlying
infrastructure
customers are not expected in case of
workflows
to look into the storage or think about
patching of the underlying components
this is all taken care of
another element that is fully taken care
of is the scale regardless if you need
to run one workflow execution per week
one per day or 1000 per second we got it
covered the product automatically scales
and it also scales down to zero which
means that if you're not running your
workflows for some time
you don't have any executions your cost
is also going down to zero
we assume that some of our customers may
want to use workflows in
latency sensitive workloads
for instance having a customer having a
user waiting on the other side of the
screen
for an outcome of a workflow execution
to support those cases we have
engineered the product in a way that
step transitions are very quick so that
we don't introduce unnecessary latency
in the execution of a business workflow
we have also taken care of time it takes
to start a new workflow execution
and there is no so-called code start so
what it
practically means is that starting a new
workflow execution is not only quick
but also predictable and deterministic
the product comes with built-in security
features first of all
you cannot make unauthenticated requests
so there's no risk of somebody
for instance a bad actor or somebody
accidentally
calling out your workflow and starting
the execution when not expected
the product also comes with full
integration with identity and access
management
of google cloud which means that you can
use it to orchestrate the work of other
google cloud products with built-in
authentication without
worrying about tokens and other elements
related to authentication to those
if you need to make requests to external
apis and you need to manage
secrets or passwords accordingly you can
use
secret manager for this integration and
make secure calls to external apis as
well
and obviously the product comes with
encryption at rest and in transit
provided that you're using
https endpoints
by now you're probably wondering how do
i model a workflow can you show me an
example of how to do this
and here it comes on the left hand side
we're seeing an example of the workflow
which consists of first a call to a
cloud function
then based on the outcome of that cloud
function we're checking a condition with
a transaction number is greater than 100
and if so we want to trigger an
execution
of a cloud-run deployment otherwise we
do not
the right-hand side is showing the
source code that implements this
specific
workflow in our product so the first
step is making a call to a cloud
function
as part of http get request and we're
also passing some inputs to that
specific function
we're also saying that we want to have
the outcome of that step
stored in metric result variable this is
a workflow variable we're going to use
later on
in the second step of the workflow we
have a conditional
statement which checks whether a value
in this case transaction number which is
an outcome of the first step
is greater than 100 and if so we're
making a call to a cloud run deployment
using https post methods and by the way
we're also passing the outcome of the
first step
to the second step as part of the call
to this um
cloud run deployment so this is a short
example
but this is just to show you how you can
model a workflow
using our syntax using our language we
took a lot of effort to ensure that this
language is
as brief as clear to read and write in
as possible
to give the maximum benefit to our
developers
let's have a quick look at the demo of
our product
let's imagine that we want to build an
ecommerce workflow
that sends an invoice to a customer the
input to the workflow
will be an id of a user that we want to
perform this operation for
the first step of the workflow will be
reading
a record for that specific user from our
firestore database
if the amount due equals to zero we are
finishing the execution at this point
because there is nothing to do
otherwise we want to generate an invoice
and send it over as an email
we're going to use a cloud function to
generate an invoice as a pdf
and then we want to make a request to an
external service
to send an email since this is an
external service we first need to
retrieve a secret
to be able to authenticate to that
service let's see how this could be
implemented in our product
a source code of a workflow is a yaml
structure
in the first step of the workflow we're
making a request to firestore api
passing an argument being an id of a
user
and reading it from the database this
obviously needs to be an authenticated
request as otherwise
firestore wouldn't let us read anything
and this is what these two lines of the
workflow code to do
whatever the output is of that step is
stored in a user record
variable in the next step of the
workflow
we're going to check whether a specific
field in the response amounted you
equals to zero
now the response of the first step was a
json
string and workflow engine is smart
enough to convert that into a dictionary
that we can use to validate whether the
amount matches our expectations
if this condition is met the workflow
execution finishes
with no amount due message otherwise it
proceeds to the next step
being a function call using a post
request
to our pdf generator function again this
is an authenticated request
because we don't want our function to be
executed by anyone and as a
request body we're also passing the
contents
that we want to have in our pdf so that
our function knows what to generate
the output of that request is stored in
a pdf output variable
which will actually be the contents of
the pdf file that we want to use as an
attachment
in the next step we're making a request
to secret manager api
to read a specific secret in my case
called
email key and then we're going to use
that secret in the request
to our email sending service and this is
what the last step of the workflow
does and as you can see we're also
including here
an attachment being the pdf output body
which is the response of the function
generating our pdf
and as the very last step of the
workflow we are
responding with a message sending that
the user was sent an invoice for a
specific amount
so with that let's test it out and let's
see if it actually works
let me first show you the entry for a
user we're going to be testing it for
which is smith dot j apparently he has
784 dollars
amount that we need to send an invoice
for and by the way if you're interested
the function that we're using to
generate a pdf
is based on an open source package
available as a pipe
module so let's now execute this
workflow
and see if it works so as an input i'm
passing an id of our user
smith dot j and i'm requesting an
execution of the workflow
as you can see execution state is active
but let's refresh and see if it's done
apparently it is so the output of the
workflow is the user was sent an invoice
for 784 dollars
which is what we expect because this is
what we saw in the database
now i also happen to have an email
account for that user
and as you can see we actually got an
email that we were expecting
with the pdf attachment let's have a
look
and the value matches our expectation
because this is exactly what we saw in
the database
so with this short demo you were able to
see that
we were able to orchestrate the work of
different google cloud products
including firestore cloud function
or google secret manager as well as
making a request to an external service
to send our email
and orchestration of all of those tasks
was performed flawlessly by
workflows let's now have a look into the
pricing model
first of all we wanted to design a
pricing model that
follows the promise of serverless
scalability which means
we want the cost of using the product to
grow
exactly as the usage grows in other
words the moment you go down to zero
because you have an idle
period or you don't need to execute a
workflow for whatever business reasons
we don't want to charge for this
specific scenario
and therefore the more you run your
workflows the higher
obviously the cost will be following
exactly your demand and following the
growth of your business
we differentiate two types of steps in
our pricing model
the pricing is based on number of
executed steps
in a workflow internal steps relate to
all the elements you can call within the
google cloud like cloud functions
or cloud run or internal variable
assignments or expression evaluations
within the google
cloud workflow product itself for all
those operations the cost is one
cent per 1000 steps executed
for external requests which are all the
http requests going to the outside world
to non-google domain names
the cost is two and a half cents per
1000
steps for both of those types of steps
there is a free tier
so if you just want to give it a try you
want to see what this product is capable
of or you're a hobbyist and you just
want to
try it out you can use a free tier and
basically
get experience uh from using the product
and then decide
whether you want to move on with further
implementations
so the free tier is 5000 internal steps
per month
or 2 000 external steps per month
with this i wanted to very warmly invite
you all
to our beta that is available right now
to our product to start using it let us
know your feedback let us know
what features you like about this
product with features you don't like
or what features you feel like are
missing or are preventing you from using
this product
to a bigger extent we're very keen to
listen and hear your feedback and i'm
looking forward
to more interactions we are also very
committed to this product
we are going to launch it to the new
availability
by the end of 2020 with this
i wanted to thank you very much for
attention and wish you
happy development of google cloud
workflows thank you very much
you